what's up it's Hannibal Burris catch me
on the bootleg Kev podcast
hey what's up it's Hannibal Burris Su
tune catch me on the bootleg Kev podcast
exclusively on Deezer
what's up
it's your boy s YouTube catch me on the
bootleg Kev podcast only on kazad
bootleg cat podcast special guest here
I'm very excited about this interview
Hannibal Burris Hannibal Burris slash
sutone
uh and then my jumping ahead in the
interview my bad man
I just feel you know it's I have to do
it oh listen dude I've been a big fan of
yours for a very long time I'm like a
comedy nerd so I uh every piece of
YouTube clip of your stand up I've
consumed and I just think you're a
[__] hilarious guy thank you man yeah
appreciate it though um interviews you
do man yeah thanks man good interviews
you do good work I appreciate your
homework yeah I try man I try
um so let's let's so listen man you
obviously have kind of always
uh I feel like it's always been pretty
evident that you're a hip-hop head
um
and you sent me a your song veneers yeah
yeah now veneers I'm glad that someone
touched on this subject right because
not only in hip-hop but really in
hip-hop these veneers are running amok
AR these [__] Chompers these giant
pearly [__] I got I got a friend
named uh A.D huh
and he's got the biggest teeth on a
human being I've ever seen and they're
not his teeth
there's so many the babies got their
Chompers Gucci's got the Chompers
everybody's got the Chompers why make a
song about the veneers uh
you know I got mine in
20 I think it's 2012 2013 when I got him
well you have veneers I got yeah I
wasn't it was the the song is uh well
your veneers don't look fake which is
good I think because I got them in a
time where they weren't super pushed and
marketed someone [__] weren't doing
bad jobs or something you know what I
mean where or or the over-the-top
veneers yeah because yours look natural
I would never yeah I think I got a good
dentist uh the reason I did the song I
had alluded to it and stand up before
about the veneers I call them tvt
and
I was I saw a thumbnail on YouTube about
somebody saying they had hair plugs and
so it made me think about things I had
gotten and so I thought about my veneers
and that could be a that's an
interesting song concept with veneers
being a placeholder for anything people
get to cover up something right you know
what I mean veneer the teeth thing is is
one thing but and so just uh if the song
did one version of it
uh the the demo of it has I do a drum
solo and a terrible jump solo and I'm
screaming I'm not going to splice I'm
not going to splice it's going crazy on
the drums that's such a like inside joke
amongst producers yeah that's why it's
not in the song anymore it's such a
niche like
like point zero zero zero five percent
of the popular like he would get it yeah
yeah so but uh it was a you know I like
I produced it a little bit on the on the
mode uh synthesizer app just to simple
with them down
uh and it was just a fun fun record that
I believed in and I performed to that
bruise of Thanksgiving
2021 Danny Brown's event in Detroit
um and it just went crazy it was just
really live and you know this is a song
that wasn't out right right never heard
it which is hard to it's super it was
crazy people were rocking to it I think
because it's slower and just easy to
catch on but and so that was really
exciting and then
one you know since Danny liked the song
asked him to be on the remix because he
had veneers
one of my uh one of the few guys who
needed them truly
I would say anybody needs veneer well he
was missing he had missing space yeah
what's that you know is it yeah it was
kind of his trademark local yeah it was
kind of kind of took away from like you
know his trademark a little bit Yeah you
can still eat you know it's not you know
it's not like having you know it's other
things that could be worse
that's the thing too with the song now
because I'm like oh man
I didn't really mean it to be telling
other [__] that you need
veneers it was more of about it was like
a self-roasting celebration a little bit
at the same time more so than like hey
[__] out there random person
with bad teeth I don't care about your
teeth that much I was making fun of
myself but I understand it's in a song
now so people can take it a certain way
it is what it is so let me ask you this
the dark side of the veneers yeah
underneath your videos they're little
little like little things little dubs
fangs yeah yes yeah and underneath is
Fang speaking they shaved them down to
me up for the amazing yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I saw there's a rapper named
beat king from Houston and uh he got
veneers and uh he posted the picture in
the dentist chair with Justice
crazy
I like to go back and get anything
because I'd be so self-conscious to eat
certain stuff right do you like not [__]
with an apple unless it's with a fork
nah man I really you know yeah I just
eat whatever man I I know that yeah you
know Judgment Day Will Come and this I'm
gonna be but you just get them fixed up
it ain't that bad
um what for you like first of all how
long have you
been like working on music behind the
scenes because we know you as an actor
as a comedian as you know an Entertainer
so like obviously like you had a music
itch to scratch so like yeah is this
something you've always done we just
didn't know about it I recorded music
before I ever did stand up probably my
last year at high school my homie Dave
had this I forget the name of this beat
machine with a blue he made some beats
on there I just made some really some
really bad fun songs back then right now
before I ever did stand up um
and then just early on in my stand-up
was always adjacent to it from the very
beginning from hosting you know open
mics to I battle wrapped in college just
because it wasn't that much stage time
to do comedy so it was just you know
battle rapping it's about getting that
reaction so I said you know I think this
is an opportunity for me to perform so
yeah from doing skits on people's albums
for sure talking and and hosting shows
uh opening on folks shows to you know
having music on my show it's always been
you know I've been directly adjacent
yeah you've always kind of you've like I
said you've been in you've been involved
in like hip-hop culture from the jump I
feel like so it's like for you it's like
do you have to have a certain level of
confidence to be like I'm gonna because
it's a vulnerable thing to put music out
into the world as a as somebody who's
known for this other stuff yeah you're
kind of putting yourself out there for
criticism and it's your art at the end
of the day right so like was was there a
certain was it that moment where you
performed the song like are you was this
just always the plan like it was a plan
but it would definitely that part of it
because I was talking about driving the
project since 2013-14 but uh
that was an ongoing process of just you
know I'm doing this [__] uh and I know I
could do it and just be in it and so I
think doing more shows helped
you know [__] that because that's where
I come from do a stand-up you just do
stand up repeatedly so I was just doing
hella shows and that would just help
build it and then it helped me form my
new songs My First project those songs I
like them and there's some some fun
stuff on there but they were kind of
made during you know 2020 2021 not
really informed by performing right so
now
the songs you know
I've performed them before I put them
out so I'm tweaking them too sometimes
I'm rewriting and and seeing what
connects with an audience or recording
after doing a show after having that
type of energy so yes it took a while to
to just Build It Up just because
especially when finances involved and of
course yeah it costs money and then just
that's where the money's coming from
like that's not what the offers are
coming from you know initially people
aren't hey come rap it's just that's all
me a certain that side and people hey
come to a movie come do stand up come do
this come do all these other things
except for what I'm actually uh spending
my days doing so navigating that part
because that's not what the the external
communication was it was something but
now let's just I'm in a good place I've
done a bunch of shows how to
fun opportunities last year that you
know I know I'm in a situation that
the average up and coming rapper is not
in just because of my previous career so
I get a couple looks that I'm gonna
[__] right now and people are I mean
they didn't even have you know racked up
a lot of friends along the way
you know yeah man it was it's so it's
been people been really supportive
Beyond you know whatever and that's what
I try to focus on now is it's always
going to be even when I started doing
comedy some folks no don't do comments
right so that you that's with anything
but it's been so many people that's
super supportive and helped out from you
know
uh The Roots I went out there and
wrapped that Pitchfork with them you
know and uh John Mulaney was playing
United Center he was like you want to
open I'm like I want to rap he's like
all right so I got the rap and United in
front of a comedy audience with 12 000
people but it's uh and then it was who
you are you know yeah you're like oh
[__] that's Hannibal yeah it's Hannibal
oh he's rapping all right I guess I
guess we're here for it but I don't know
you know it's so it's uh it's been it's
been really exciting because it puts me
in that
that mode of
of uh
that I was in when I first started doing
stand-up where I don't have that with
stand up now I'll do some stand up but
it's it's for the dough like I'm not
showing up to to pop up but I'll show up
to I'll show up at a hip-hop over Mike
and I'll rap for 11 people you know what
I'm saying it's almost like you're like
like because I feel like that is a part
of like when you always hear comedians
talking about like the come up going to
The Comedy Store doing all these open
mics trying to do five shows in one
night to work on your material yeah it
feels like
like one of those times in your life
where you probably reflect on and be
like man that energy I had when I was
just trying to make it yeah it's similar
it's similar now it's that feeling now
because every because it's a lot of
different
possibilities and and you know it's a
different conversation with the audience
through the music it's similar as
communication but it's a different you
know conversations different structure
to it the the Beats can guide you a
little bit and
um
it's been it's been cool man I'm and and
the records is getting better and the
show is getting better and and and we're
learning and and releasing music is
doing music is a skill you grow at that
releasing music is a skill too in itself
and so I'm learning that part of it like
how to drop music and how to and so
it's just all the growth and excitement
I'm I'm hyped every day man yeah you
said previous career so you're done with
like stand up and acting uh not done but
I ain't
you're focused on me dude I'll do I'll
do comedy to cover the cost right now
that's what it really is your comedy
career is
now funding your music and it's just and
just allowing me to finish I did a
University Wisconsin Milwaukee
um they've booked if their comedy you
know night for the semester and so
I do my [__] I had a band there and so I
usually my recent comedy gigs I'll just
do songs at the end after doing an hour
whatever now let me try this format I'm
doing I'm starting off two songs then I
do 20 minutes to stand up do another
song in the middle and coming in like 30
minutes to stand up and then close out
two songs you know that's kind of dope
it's a fun show man that'd be a great
show to see it's a fun show and it keeps
it Lively for me and it makes and that's
so I enjoy doing stand-up in that
scenario with the with the band playing
under and it's just creating a a whole
vibe last year I was very I was in my
I'm doing music mode and I was turning
down a lot of [__] with standout no I'm
trying to rap it like we don't know
about you know all right pass and so now
I figure out how to how do you do both
how to finagle it like oh I just you
know once I'm an adult you ain't gonna
fool me out the stage anyway for rapping
yeah like I'm on stage already so it's
not to talk yeah uh yeah so it's it's
there now I'm in that zone of you know
figuring out how to make it work and and
that
so
locked in on oh this is the identity I'm
doing music right now leaving the phone
don't talk to me about no like that's
where I was I was in a real that's like
because it was still fresh you know your
mind stay changes and grows so it's uh
it's hella exciting man it's a fun time
man you got a healthy balance between
the two yeah and it's a dope show or
another format I do if I'm playing you
know music venue pop up small cap like
300 500.
I have opener then I do stand up then I
have the band Jam or a music opener or
two 15 20 minutes let me come back out I
come back out do the mute it's so then
I've you know I'm warmed up because I
already done some standard so I'm loose
too you know what I mean so and it's a
separate set change fits or something
throwing some [__] you know what I mean
like making a whole different thing so
it's been cool to kind of figure out the
live experience because I really care
about the the live show and making the
[__] dope and on point and and you know
when folks come out the house to see you
it's a very important thing so there's
been times where I didn't
do you know nailed it or I was you know
finding it in on [__] and so now I
really cherish the live experience and
how to make it really dope I always say
that like the hardest like probably
bravest thing anybody can do is just
[__] go on stage and try to do stand
up because your job is literally like
you're the like the
feedback is instant you know whether or
not you're good because people aren't
there to fake laugh and they're not
there to they want to laugh people are
there to laugh so if you bomb it's like
it's got to be just I don't know man I
mean how do you compare that to getting
comfortable on stage as a rapper because
you're already comfortable on stage like
this is kind of what you do so the with
the rapping you could do a lot
on your own
I think you can
if you really have been about it
you can really improve your stage show
as a musician
you can take Leaps and Bounds over the
course of
three months you know what I mean right
like just huge leaps yeah you can say
huge leaps in three months as far as
your music show stand up I don't know if
you take the same leaps three years reps
it comes through you know yeah life
experience it comes from sin back and
then you get better you know you know
what I mean so that's the one where you
know you can kind of
um
you can even in process you could
pull things from people with in this
being in the studio it's not stealing
something it's just like oh I see I'm a
father just get the thought you see like
you hear somebody rap and say okay get
in the booth get that down you know like
somebody's assistant that that gets
other people that act on their instincts
in the in the room right I think like
sharing creative juices is a little bit
more encouraging yeah that type is so
like if you sample some [__] or like
took a Cadence from another song and put
it on your song it's it's not like a
crazy thing in comedy if they perceive
you stealing jokes you almost like it
kind of like blackballed a little yeah
it's a uh you just lose yourself in this
[__] more uh where
I was on this show recently I was uh
trying to
it's a lot to think about if you want to
think about it while you're in in
yourself you know what I mean you could
if you got banned you got lights yeah
it's a lot it's a lot to think about if
you want to think about it but then I
had the middle of the show I was just
like just worry about the next line and
saying the [__] out of that and the
physicality that comes with that like
each each bar and just and then that
compounds throughout the show and then
the show it just went up one of my best
shows because the energy was there and I
just focused on each line and just being
in it and so
um yeah man it's been
it's been a real cool time because
you know last year this show was better
than last year's show
next year's show gonna be better than
this year's show and so on and so forth
uh you grew up in Chicago right yeah
um so give me kind of your like uh
what are what like what are what are you
growing up listening to like what are
the albums that kind of formed your your
hip-hop fandom as a as a as a young man
yo what's good man we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our good
Folks at my bookie that's right man NBA
season is uh winding down playoffs are
going down so many ways you can get
money you could bet on who you think's
gonna win the finals you can get your
prop bets per game uh we are finally
down to the final eight right now uh my
sons ain't looking good at the time of
recording not looking good uh look go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up
I've been gambling on my Boogie for over
10 years so listen come and join me
let's get this money together
mybookie.ag when you use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up use that promo
code you're going to get that deposit
bonus that deposit bonus is crazy it's
the sign up bonus you get and uh not
only are basketball football which is
starting to creep up on us baseball's
back MLB baseball man all season long
you get this money plus they got the
online casino if you're into craps
Blackjack roulette [__] slot machines
whatever it is go to mybookie.ag right
now use that promo code bootleg and get
that free deposit bonus that's how we're
doing things all right also I want to
give a big shout out to the homies of
King Palm man these are our new sponsors
at King Palm now this is the thing about
these King Palms man these things right
here
ah natural natural leaves free of
tobacco and additives the only thing I
smoke out of and what's dope is they got
these other ones right these uh this is
one of their more popular items right
here
great flavor
these are the leaf rolls they hold a
gram each and they got the terpene fused
tips which means you squeeze and you pop
the tip while you're smoking your flour
and you get a little burst of flavor
these are the peach pineapples
um they got the energy drink flavor they
got blue blueberry watermelon all kinds
of [__] man
um so what's dope if you go to
kingpom.com and use the promo code
bootleg cab right now you're gonna get
half off half off half off kingpom.com
tobacco free
natural
raps all right and also don't forget if
you're in a I don't know wherever you're
at go to 7-Eleven they got them your
local smoke shop one of the most
successful uh businesses in the game
when it comes to the all-natural Leaf
the most successful no tobacco no
nicotine just natural Leafs to stuff
your flour in and in case you did not
know they also have
whatever size King Palm this is
this is a giant Leaf wrapped around yeah
wrapped around some premium can I buy
shout out to uh King Palm go follow one
more time kingpound.com promo code
bootleg Kev say 50 off let's get back to
the interview Crucial Conflict oh [__]
the final tick yeah come on hey hey
Showdown yeah I'm from the west side of
Chicago
Wild Style there was a game Wild Side
there's a guy named never I think yeah
it's a cohort cohort yeah I [__] love
that album
goes crazy anywhere in Chicago do you
like the original hair the remix
uh
uh I like the original but it might be
so there's like a remix but I remember
the remix there was like a remix that I
I I'm probably the only person on Earth
who likes the hay remix more than the
original because I found the hey remix
first on like a one of those [__]
singles who used to be able to buy like
the warehouse or yeah
so I only had the remix and then I got
the album and the original was like a
little slower yeah and I was like I
already thought that the remix was the
original one yeah it is yeah so I hear
the original and it's just like hey the
remixes I hate that hey now we smoking
on hey that's just a [__] anyway
continue that's I am with California
Love there's a re there's a remix with
the doo doo doo yeah but the more
popular one
this is the better one but I guess it's
all it's a matter of taste it's awesome
objective man do or die
man listen yeah Do or Die po Pimpin I
love do or die and Juke Music Man Juke
music not on the rap but that's just the
production of Juke music is a big
influence I pre you know I produce
sometimes too so my track but I was at
the airport is kind of that faster Pace
chaotic yeah one sample you know was
that big in Chicago yeah that was just
always you know if you go to a party in
high school it'll play all Juke songs
for about two hours and then one slow
song at the end at the end of the party
what was the name of the Do or Die album
where it was a penny was it Picture This
Is that the name of that album yeah you
like if you the Do or Die album it was a
penny like the CD itself when you took
it out yeah I think it was called
picture this I could be wrong I don't
remember but that's the one that had po
Pimpin on it okay oh man I like steel
pole Pimpin is a dope remix too like a
dope that was they even have like a
little uh that they had a song uh
[__] what was the song that they had
like maybe like in 2007 eight they had
some [__] man shout out to them I
remember when they had like a there was
like the Crucial Conflict like the super
subliminal beef going on with Bone Thugs
oh yeah
yeah they will they will be dude I had
that track where yay higher
when you hear the song You Know
there was a lot of random Chicago
artists in the Kanye initial like wave
that I checked out just because they had
yay Beats
yeah bomb J no Bump J for sure there was
another dude there was like one dude who
I'm was he white or was he not white
they was like I forget I wish David was
here he would tell me but we we would
always just like going [__] Napster
and just find random Kanye production
and be like yeah who the [__] this guy
yeah but yeah man so how cause how old
are you 40. okay so I'm 36. so so I'm
like right behind you but my cousins and
every I mean I got put on a Crucial
Conflict as when I was like eight
in Chicago did you guys ever get the
brother Lynch [__] did that ever reach
you over there what was that
Brother Lynch Hung
oh man Brother Lynch Hung back Peak wild
horrorcore rap yeah like crazy
I probably when I was like seven or
eight got my first Brother Lynch Hung CD
and I was I actually believed them
so like he's on this [__] album and
he's talking about like cannibalism
eating babies and [__] it's crazy oh
damn he's a he signed a tech nine now
which makes sense but yo it's crazy it's
like some Sacramento like wild [__] so I
just didn't know if like you know
because the Chicago [__] hit me I don't
know if the West Coast underground like
underbelly horrorcore rap was he flowing
no was he he could wrap his ass off okay
because that's the thing was he flowing
like remember just like saying that [__]
he was just saying it and then letting
the beat breathe and he just was like
you know brother Lynch he has a an album
called season of The Sickness
um
this the album
hold on what's the [__] song where
he's talking about
when you see me put that night up in
that [__] hole [__] it back slow come
on man
that's all over the room
this whole song is about him feeding his
children other children
I'll get that in though it's like that
wait wait it gets weird
tell you I'm still recovering from the
opening line you better pray when I put
my nine up in your puzzle
watch
[Music]
and watch the baby brains drip out their
fetus
guess what daddy's bringing home for
supper that's a guts and slaps a human
meat [__] now eat
yeah
that's the that's the power of flow and
Melody man
that song has eight million listens on
Spotify right now
classic
it's just you know there was like that
weird horrorcore like there was like
necro and like yeah uh I just and I
actually like thought that was real so I
was always like damn I don't know if I
should have the CD as a kid and [__] but
yeah
I mean he had that that Niche like I'm
glad I could I'm glad I could uh educate
you on Brother Lynch Hung yeah I'm about
to yeah don't leave he's like I'm not
about to listen to that ever again I
have to now even if no that's the thing
is now I have to so you're kind of like
around this like you're really coming up
on like common drops resurrection and
like can I borrow a dollar and like
they're super early common sense [__]
like so my high school yeah yeah well
yeah so I graduated in 2000 trying to
think of what albums I I had early on
like Reasonable Doubt drop I had to uh
rake Raekwon only building links that
Naz verse on Verbal Intercourse I didn't
I didn't know what he was talking about
as a kid but that [__] sounded Fly And I
memorized it uh
but I had I like novelty stuff back then
too as a kid I remember having uh Deion
Sanders must be the money uh 95 south I
moved there like that [__] that you know
the Deion Sanders yeah yeah man there
was a CD that I had as a kid and it was
um every diff it was like a compilation
and every song was a different NBA
player rapping oh yeah and like Jason
Kidd had a song [__] Mitch Richmond
had a song it was just like terrible
music but I bought it because I was like
a basketball fan and I was like wait I
could hear all these NBA players rap it
was a bad bad purchase at the end of the
day but
yeah do you think
Shaq did it all right he has some joints
he's just having a bet is it more about
them having is this who in the room with
them to get it yeah cause I think Shaq
had some [__] yeah you have to you know
to uh you can't stop the arrests good
presence too just yeah black thought on
[__] he had he he before once that um
Jay-Z NOS beef got out of hand you could
actually go back and Shaq had a song
with both of them on the same record
yeah yeah so was it uh these basketball
players were they really bad I think
Shaq was actually a decent rapper yeah
or with the other ones though were they
necessarily bad or they just had bad a r
i don't know did you ever hear Kobe song
uh uh I did but it doesn't it's not good
yeah it's like and then you have like
[__] AI who was dropping like you
know he had he was like Allen Iverson
AKA Jules and he had an album that was
just all kinds of [__] Street [__]
you know I think he might have gotten in
trouble for putting that out I don't
remember he was talking some crazy [__]
as like a millionaire as like a guy
who's got his own Reebok shoe
yeah people got to express man sometimes
this is some stuff that you can't say
with the dribble with a jump shot you
know you gotta just get in the stew and
let that [__] fly for sure you gotta you
know hey I don't want to say this with
20 000 people around me I'm gonna say
this by myself who is your in your like
uh go-to when it comes to artists that
you're you've you've got you know
obviously building friendships with
where you can send them records and get
their opinion back on them
uh
uh Open Mic Eagle I sent him a lot of
stuff
um
but yeah I said open my Google some
stuff
who else
I was sending I was seeing a lot of
people stuff when I made my track kept
about three it used to be called Kawaii
freestyle it was like 14 minutes long
and I was it was November 2020 so
pandemic pandemic oh yeah that's the
perfect time that I would never send
people just a 14 Minute Freestyle now
but I was so hyped about it and I just
felt I felt the progression and just
liked how the track sounds and I was
just sending out to everybody it was
just like hey look I can rap for 14
minutes it was
it wasn't all cool he's we had it yeah
it definitely has you know we cut it
down but it was an exciting time I was
sitting that to everybody I I knew at
the time I said that's a hell of people
just hey look I have sent this [__]
um but yeah might give some good good
feedback on stuff and
uh
I said stuff to fly low sometimes I said
you know just see what he thinks
but uh yeah it's been it's been dope man
it's just you know just keep on learning
progressing
I want to be able to play drums in my
set three five years from now you know
I'm practicing [__] and really [__]
awesome pack out there you know that
show that I'm seeing him live though
crazy and I didn't he'd be on YouTube's
doing the whole [__] like and I remember
seeing that Pitchfork he is back really
I didn't know you could do that I
thought I didn't know that was possible
I thought that was for my mother you
playing keys or playing guitar or are
they only on the mic and at the drug
he's just shredding on the drums while
doing all his verses yeah that [__] is
tough yeah he's an alien for sure so uh
yeah man it's been you know it's dope to
learn and
this is exciting time man it's for sure
it's time just to work on the work on
the [__] and get in the detail of it
um I we talked about this off off the
air but I was telling you how much I
loved you on that Eric Andre show yeah
that show was revolutionary in my
opinion we were talking like I feel like
it really did have a like heavy
influence on guys like Caleb Presley and
homie Marco or not homie Mark homie Mark
was my friend funny Marco yeah
um and uh there was just some of the
wildest [__] ever on that show and you
were like the funniest [__] co-host
uh like give me kind of like the I know
a lot of the the people who came onto
the show had some sort of idea it was
like oh maybe a Comedy Central show but
they really didn't did most of the
people like not really have a clue what
the [__] they were walking into first
couple seasons and especially the first
season was probably the you know
the purest version of it
um
because they yeah it was but it wasn't
that many celebrities fake celebs there
were so many random guys yeah yeah for
sure the the video quality was lower it
had a different aesthetic and and that
one it really wasn't anything you know
what I mean it had no no history or no
footprint for people to to research
right so it was just people the folks
that work you know popping on with
taking a chance shout out to
Dolph Lundgren and
Sinbad who else was on that first season
but those are fun man uh and then as it
grew
some people were fans of it right
everyone would come up and then I think
some people still didn't you know know
about it I can't speak for everybody's
experience or due diligence of course of
course but uh if some people definitely
surprised and like whoa what what is
happening and people you know uh like
are you there you're you're there for
the ti episode right yeah okay so what
happens when it's cut
you know because the T I want to say the
ti episode of Dick popped up through the
table I'm not sure I know it was like
some stuff from the there was something
on the floor and then I think that he
was talking about taking a boner pill
and then a [__] dildo just shot up to
the desk and so I I'm just wondering
once it's over uh how awkward is the
like hey man
like or is it like yo [__] y'all like I
mean I I saw them at other stuff after
that but yeah I don't really
his socialized too much after or was it
like ever a point where like we didn't
see a lot of the crazy [__] like because
people were really mad or did anybody
ever get really mad because there was
some wild
um
who got mad
one chick puked Lauren Conrad yeah Laura
Conrad maybe Lou Ferrigno or something
was he seemed upset
um
yeah it didn't
it's uh
yeah it was it was
it's been a minute too like that's why
I'm like trying to yeah it's like since
the last full season I did was 20
15. you know when they had like these
versions of you after that like yeah
which was [__] hilarious yeah uh they
did you know they do good with story and
just you know having the clones and and
stuff like that but the for the final
season we're not the final season for my
final season
I only work one day that was in 2019.
uh it's a it's a well you know well made
show the chaos you know the editors
really they kill it no it's all about
the editing editing and they do really
good at like cutting cutting we'll be
writing just making you know so it'll be
stuff since I'm not in that edit
every things I forgot about sometimes
and I'm watching I didn't expect y'all
to do that uh we have some good times
speaking of TI yeah you guys are kind of
reversing here right he's a rapper yeah
trying to get into comedy right and
you're a comedian a little perceived
comedian you've always done music but
you know you're a comedian getting into
being a hip-hop artist yeah what do you
think about T.I
because I've seen him starting to like
pop up and do like more open mics and
stuff I know he was kind of like in the
beginning there was a lot of these
unsaid like comedian rules that he was
breaking that I'm sure he didn't know
about but I know he's getting a lot of
Hell amongst the community of of uh
stand up snobs but like what do you
think about tip and have you have you
got to see him live at all I haven't got
to see him live it's a tougher job man
you know what I mean to take away the
beats and those
uh
uh yeah those and then you also kind of
while you're doing stand up
your
fighting against those memories in the
crowd head you know what I mean it's a
tougher job and it's not like because
you he's on stage and they're like what
you knew about that big [__] Papa you
could do whatever you like that's that
you could do it yeah smashes you know
what I mean that they remember so it's a
tougher
you know he's taking on a real
it's challenging for you but that's the
the
musician two comedian wrote
is way tougher especially if you're like
people do it Superstar it's not like T.I
was just like you know like a yeah
decently big rapper who toured no he's
[__] TI like yeah I mean he loved you
know he wanted to take the challenge he
really he enjoyed doing it and and
getting something out of it that maybe
the music can't do right now he's still
doing music but he enjoys the stand-up
so I think you take it taking beats away
man is is tough and so it's you know he
working at that [__] and you have to
make people laugh yeah they're not gonna
laugh because they like your music right
they're gonna laugh because it's a
natural reaction to something yeah they
they that's the thing that [__] in here
you know they might show up because they
like your music
right it's a tougher it's a tougher Road
man it's a tougher Road uh that's why I
don't do it as much anymore because it
is this type I'd rather just you know
tell some stories over these beats that
I like that I and then practice that
[__]
50 times before I even see people you
know right I was gonna say for you like
how much of the music is
kind of
you know semi-comedic where you're able
to kind of like hey I might make this
song because I know it's going to be
funny and I know I can make a great
music video to make people laugh because
you played me some other [__] where you
were like barring the [__] out yeah I
mean like so for you is it like a
because you're obviously a funny guy you
enjoy creating and you know yeah I I was
battling with that early on like oh can
I do funny songs can I do but then can I
talk about this and be normal or
whatever
this is just do what
feels right or what feels good
conceptually
um
and just be honest and know it's it's
honest
Parts you know these all different parts
for nears is a real part of me the the
song about you know my upbringing in
Chicago and high school and almost
getting robbed that's a real thing so
it's just being
true to that and you know performing it
wrapping it with with Clarity and
confidence and and writing it
to the to the best of my ability and you
know
trusting it and all of that so yeah I
don't
you know someone like on a single side
right now
they're a little more playful right uh
veneers and the next one out of place
but then it's Emma you know
after the album I have
more songs that a bit grounded you know
and have elements of humor and some
songs Just barring out uh so I'm I'm
just excited to you know put together
the full project and uh what's the name
of it do you have it in there I don't
even have a name yet I was thinking
about uh calling it teetering on the
edge of reality okay uh but that's just
that's a that's a placeholder not sure
yet
have you found out like are you like
trying are you just doing it
independently are you collaborating with
a label like just independent yeah
straight Indie straight Indie yeah just
out of pocket Venice Venice yeah
District they're a great Distribution
Company they could distribute my
homegirl tweet shout out to Twitter yeah
they yeah you know they have some some
good artist Services over there uh but
yeah just you know one is do well put it
out I don't really have
I think it's got some good records man
so I'm just
excited to put out that type of body of
work and design the show around uh
around it and and have these different
experiences you know right what are your
thoughts on like because I think when I
I want to say when I first moved to LA I
moved out here the beginning of 2017 and
it felt like it was kind of like maybe
the peak of like
The Comedy Store being just like a crazy
place to go to and like yeah just pay
for a Tuesday ticket and just see who
comes like I see Chappelle there I said
it's it's a like it feels like Joe Rogan
moving to Austin and opening this comedy
Mothership and
it feels like a lot of that kind of
energy has moved to Texas like have you
got to go and check out his new club or
I haven't been to the to the club but I
I hear that people having a good time
and comedians get get paid well nice
nice facilities well-designed spot what
I've seen online about it
uh
uh yeah it's
it's dealt that he got that spot I
haven't really been out doing comedy
much in L.A man I really be at the music
stuff and then yeah I haven't um been
popping up like that but
so yeah it's so different
super different
time
um
it almost feels like nowadays right like
if you're if you're back in the day yeah
you would want to get into movies you
would want to get into having a sitcom
as a comedian
I feel like nowadays you just gotta like
you gotta kind of have a podcast
podcast I mean that's a big
that's the you know kind of the mixtape
it's like a mixtape for comedy for yeah
yeah it's like you everybody you drop
the podcast you get people excited so
then when you hit the road they come and
buy tickets yeah and they get to see you
in a you know
I mean it's still a performance but it's
it's more toned down more natural you
don't have to play for that lab so they
get to know you more as a as a human
being so this is why a lot of the folks
have found success because they and
you're able to just do it it's low cost
you do a bunch of you do five a week
you'll be like okay I'm doing a sports
when I'm doing it you could really
really work it and let people see
different
different the podcast game it's got
people playing really big buildings man
out here and selling a lot of tickets
it's uh it's a cool it's it's really
cool to see because yeah it's pretty
crazy you'll see like like shout out to
my guys shows like shows is like he was
like bringing idiots forever with
Charlotte I mean then the flagrant thing
just goes crazy and he's like a
brilliant comedian greatly yeah and to
see him do like you know some of the
venues he's doing it's just crazy it's
[__] it's dope man people just people
build it up man we all making this up so
it's just as we go you know and you know
you make it up and you keep making it up
and you may you know hey I'm doing here
I'm going here y'all coming you make you
keep making it up man and keep building
man just create a lifestyle it's uh I
think as I said I think comedy is kind
of like hip-hop like when we talk about
like the goats there's like eras like to
me like rock him
might not have like well listen rockin's
a bad example but like if you go back to
like maybe like Run DMC right like Run
DMC like started this [__] yeah Run DMC
musically or maybe even lyrically might
not necessarily be on the same level as
Kendrick Lamar but their significance to
the cultures
uh
as great or greater you know what I mean
but on the comedy side who would you say
this era of Comedy is like on the on
like let's say since you've been like
super active let's say the last 15 to 20
years like who would you put on the
Mount Rushmore it is summertime if
you're dealing with elect erectile
dysfunction Ed if you will maybe you got
stress at work maybe you're tired of
looking at the same chick maybe you just
need a little pep in your step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits
and uh it has the same active ingredient
as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it I promise you that uh
Bluetooth also is uh incredible because
not only does it come in the blue
chewable flavor with the same active
ingredient as vibrancy house but it also
has a mint chewable flavor which is the
same active ingredient as Levitra all
right all this if you're questioning I
don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this [__] work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com because it's going to get
delivered right to your house they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars
shipping that's it the bluetooth's come
into your house no awkward doctor's
appointments no awkward doctor's visits
it's all online
bluetooth.com Thank Me Later what's up
guys hey um if you are watching this and
it's April 20th 4 20.
I'm going to be hanging out at hard Dean
today
but that's right put the flyer up Little
Rock
I'll be at hardean um hanging out all
day today
um the craziest most just luxurious
illest dispensary in the world located
right in Los Vegas Nevada now Hardy in
Las Vegas they are our family they'd
sponsor the podcast I love those guys
dearly and when I say that it is the
best place I've ever walked into to buy
premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so uh what you all need to
do is go follow them online hardeen
underscore Las Vegas follow them on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're going to be
doing a lot of content in Vegas
live from Hardin they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope flag gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
get that hard eating with smells amazing
so look make sure you go to Harding uh
if you're in Vegas get in that Uber get
in that cab as soon as you touch down
say take me to hardine the taxi drivers
the Ubi drivers they know exactly where
it is because it's the hottest spot in
Vegas they go take you straight there
you're gonna tell them I sent you
they're gonna get you situated real
nicely all right Harding underscore Las
Vegas go show them some love go to
hardinglasvegas.com gotta give a shout
out to our oh geez my dogs had Odd Socks
baby they've been [__] with us from
day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and butt head socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead
drawskis bruh
oh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout at
oddsoxofficial.com using the promo code
bootleg so go right now
otsoxofficial.com my first uh suggestion
would be get you a pair or a pack of the
Odd Socks Basics the black and the
whites those are my go-to's and then you
gotta [__] with some of these Big
Lebowski socks and they just got
Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bruh what are we talking about
go to oddsoxofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview uh
so I would say
put uh
Dave
Chappelle yeah
uh you put uh
Patrice O'Neal oh yeah rest in peace
uh uh let me put uh
we put uh I don't know why this person
uh let me see Chris Rock oh yes Chris
and uh who's a fourth oh and then
let me see
who's who's it for listen strictly off
the last 20 the last 20 the last 20 of
stand up yeah like stand-up output
so you tell me okay so that's 2003 to
now
uh yeah one more slime hmm
ah
thanks for prayer Patrice O'Neill
Chris Rock
Tucker Carlson for the force
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Tucker Carl
's my goodness that's for the house I
like it so this is going to be something
we're gonna need you to sign that we're
gonna frame it we're gonna put it right
on the side
oh you know
yeah there we go there it is there it is
yeah
you know what's crazy is like taco
Carlson [__] is like
I just remember back in the day like Jon
Stewart roasting him with his little
[__] bow tie on like I think he's on
CNN then
and like it's just
he's a goof for sure yeah I don't even
and I don't you don't have to tell me I
don't even know exactly what happened I
just know they were like Tucker Carson's
out it's crazy because it happened the
same day that Don Lemon got fired okay
yeah I was I I was watching um
Roy Wood Jr the the correspondence he
killed the oh yeah he killed it but it
was a few things that I was just finding
out from him you're like wait a minute
let me yes I don't get the joke even uh
the uh the nft the Clarence Thomas joke
was was really funny but I didn't know
that that situation was going on it was
just yeah a lot of news he did his thing
on there he's I want to say did he used
to do prank calls back he's a prank
calls back that's how he started in 99.
I want to say I had like a CD of his
prank calls his prank calls were [__]
epic that's how he built his uh
following initially out of it's out of
Birmingham yeah yeah bro he's dope man
yeah Roy super dope man yeah um for you
man like uh is there any of the up and
coming artists or current artists in
hip-hop that you could like inspired by
I know you we just had Courtney's
manager here you were in his videos or
anybody who's like you know kind of in
that era of music that you actually like
because a lot of this [__] is terrible
uh it's a lot of it's a lot of good
stuff there's a lot of good stuff a lot
of good stuff out there
um
it's more on r b but I just heard it uh
the other day you know Jordan Ward I
heard it I've heard the name I haven't
he got some good tracks man his album
um
I one of them one of the songs popped up
on my Discover and then I listened to
the rest of the album but it sounds good
well produced Lido who's a really dope
producer
um produced a lot of it uh smino got a
crazy flow Cimino's fire uh his flow's
crazy and loves me
I mean
it's
who else is newer that
trying to think of folks man no smino's
fire yeah yeah yeah that's that like
that flow is is one of those things I
don't know I don't know how that's
happening
it's some people you like that's dope
but then there's some people I don't
understand how that's happening right
now yeah have you uh take take me back
as somebody who had high interest in
comedy High interest in music how dope
was it like
was there uh when the double XL cover
came out with Dave Chappelle Dead Prez I
want to say Kanye was on there Tele
quality was on there
he did such a good job of bringing the
Two Worlds together with the Chappelle
show and just I just think of that in
the block party and I just it was
amazing like like for you like how how
it you know important was that as an
up-and-coming comedian who's also
obviously an artist like
he did such a good job I think of I
really feel like he successfully
bridged like two eras of comedy and
music together definitely man it's just
how he he brings people together with
his shows and and and performances
uh it's been cool to to really watch I
snuck into a Chappelle Show years back
when I was
in Chicago I think it was 0-4005 when
he's doing stand-up yeah at the height
of Chappelle Show Congress Theater and I
didn't have money for a ticket I tried
to it was I was just started I've tried
to like go in I'm like I'm a comedian
like that doesn't no one cares nobody
cares so I just started looking around
the building just found an Open Door got
in and got in and uh so it was did I was
wild and then the you know years later
do a lot of shows with him uh it made it
super surreal like damn I used to sneak
in your [__] he's super cool too yeah I
got really high with him once uh it was
actually a core Days album release party
it was me Dave Chappelle
and uh
the guy who played Steve Urkel
IO
white yeah and I was like
this is interesting like what is
happening right now yeah man someone
told me as a 12 year old I'd be in a
[__] joint circle with Dave Chappelle
and Steve her I had a Steve Urkel toy as
a kid like though I pull this did I do
that like yeah it's crazy man life is
made up man stuff be happy yeah uh when
do you plan on putting out this this
album man
July July Target is July 21st
um
and then
looking to do I'm doing sobs June 14th
hey that's a big deal for any up and
coming hip-hop artist to do an SOB show
I'm I'm hyped about it man just you know
I've performed there years back 10 years
ago [__] with uh
uh with chance actually I did stand up
before chance massive rap 2013 yeah
um I just celebrated that birthday of
that so shout out to chance
and so I'm yeah I'm hyped to do sobs man
you're headliner yeah headline I'm gonna
do I'm gonna do the you know stand up
and music set so I do stand up at the
beginning
special guests and stuff and who's
opening for you a comedian or an artist
uh
uh I think I'm gonna have one comedian
one artist hmm uh maybe a couple artists
probably have my guy highlight Supreme
this dope singer he produced one of my
track knee brace and uh this other track
Paradox uh on my project and so he's
amazing performer he actually he giving
me little tips in the studio where he'll
say hey you got a smile right you're
recording they can hear it they can hear
it through the mic they can hear it
through the mic and so I'll do a tag and
be sounding and so I'll be doing a take
and then it'll sound flat
and then I'll read I'll re-cut and and
smile and it sound completely different
than you think that's true yeah that's
somewhere I mean that's like the little
[__] like that yeah you gotta you kind
of know from being in the studio so much
yeah he just he'll he'll stand in front
of you like hey man
like doing warm-up [__] and so it's
always just tough to learn from folks
it's always something to
to learn from and and improve as far as
the studio and the show man
um so yeah it's gonna be in I'm I'm the
show gonna be on on point SOB's
Wednesday SOB's June 14th if you're
gonna do anything in L.A
I'll do some uh I'm trying to do the
Moroccan it might be in the fall when
I'm in La I don't have anything set but
I'll do something in La soon probably
around the album drop better be dope
yeah
um I always wonder like with the you
know we always hear about like how it's
a little harder to do certain jokes
nowadays because people get offended
yeah I think a lot of that's a little
blown out of proportion but you know it
we are in a much more sensitive climate
a much more divisive climate right do
you think it's a lot harder for
stand-up comedians nowadays
I can't speak to it like for real and
you know because I'm not living it in
the same way even like two or three
years ago like you know like I feel like
it's just like
people get I just I feel like people are
as much as they want to laugh they also
want to get offended nowadays you gotta
do your [__] man you know what I mean
like that ain't gonna really you know
it's always
as many people as if people offended
there's gonna be other people that want
that type of stuff so you just worry
about your show worry about who's there
and and just write and perform to the
best of your ability and instincts and
that's that's the gig were you doing any
of the uh stuff in Ohio during the
pandemic like those shows that Dave was
doing
I did one
what was that like because he was kind
of like the first guy still kind of like
you I I've heard about it like you had
to like get tested on the spot it was
outside it was in the middle of nowhere
there's a lot of people taking flights
to Ohio to go to this because it was
almost like the only thing yeah I gotta
get to Ohio because I can go watch
Comedy you know like yeah I did it was
before because I did a drive-in tour
which I regret how was that
terrible yeah it was bad but it was just
you know you wanted to do something and
then that first show
after that first show I said how many of
these we got what am I doing
I didn't cancel the whole [__] man
[Laughter]
it was you know because the comedy how
many comedians were on tour with you
it was uh
it was it was my date so I brought
brought a couple folks I think yeah
probably one or two folks
and then I did uh a double bill
with Thundercat at the in the Rose Bowl
parking lot
um but it was just doing stand up in
that setting
it just gotta be gotta wait because you
want you waiting for the reaction and
you they're in that car so they stand
sitting outside but they're not even
it's not a typical outdoor game where
everybody except yeah so there's no vibe
I think I mean I'll hopefully never have
to do something like that again but I
know how I'd approach it now you wanna
you would do that and if I had to do
stand up in that setting again I would
do it in tandem with somebody because
then you you can bounce off of each
other on stage or I would be doing doing
music which uh yeah it was with The
Cleveland Show
was the first order to her
it was by interstate
so on stage your eye line is interstate
so just trucks going and then
to my right is train tracks Jesus and
then the train got really active during
my set oh yeah it was just so much going
and this is my first
uh probably your first time doing stand
up in a while because first time doing
stand up in a while and I just uh
I think maybe a day or two before I
found out my daughter was gonna be born
but I did not want to talk about it
there right in this so that's really
what's on my mind yeah and then I got
these other so I wasn't really able to
give a honest show or a focus show
because I see a FedEx you see trucks and
trains keep on going but then they were
all in the car
so they got perfect audio of me just
bitching about the train so it's not
it's not the same as when
there's a Heckler or something like
everybody this motherfucker's loud yeah
and you roast them in there
my experience
in on stage was completely separated
from this experience in the car so I
just made it it was a weird gig man it
was a weird guy I'll never forget it but
some of them got better over time how
many did you do I think we did maybe six
or seven you can think uh the Burke
Chrysler guy I think he did like I think
he kind of like did that yeah the whole
time like he was just it's doable
I'm not saying it's definitely not you
know it's not the preferred yeah
and it's not you know we ain't you know
it got better towards the end once we
figured it out you kind of get the
figured out what this is the vibe okay
this is it this is how I'm gonna feel
I had this bit that we were doing you
know like since we're doing drive-ins I
make this character called marshmallow
it's a DJ character same aesthetic as
marshmallow but only playing songs about
driving so cruising by uh Smokey
Robinson all these got drive slow that's
his whole playlist is it and made a
costume form for the character and
everything and I'm thinking this shit's
about to go crazy at the first show and
it was like oh no feasible they not
really [__] with carmelo like that
we've got a I had a designer for this
she didn't she didn't she didn't glued a
bunch of Matchbox cars to a jumpsuit you
had the whole [__] suit costume
everything yeah and then it was like
okay we have to we have to figure out
how to introduce marshmallow better in
these other cities like okay Carmelo
needs a hype man I can't just be out
there on his own right it was you know
it was experiment it was fun but those
those gigs man they would definitely
they were something yeah something
though yeah I can imagine so what was
the Chappelle setting like obviously
during the pandemic because you said you
only did one of them right I did one of
them uh and that was right before though
so it was
it was I remember
as if I specifically remember being
backstage
and I hadn't been anywhere in a minute
especially not a show and so I remember
they had maybe some Jolly Ranchers or
something some type you know oh yeah
I had to be snacks and [__] down like
backstage I forgot like I don't I don't
even remember anymore yeah oh yeah you
sometimes you do go backstage [__] yeah
everyone's got access to the same Bowl
so let me put this Jolly Rancher in some
before I open it
uh and so I had a good set man but it
was definitely I remember not being
fully
feeling fully socialized yeah such a
weird time yeah being in a room and kind
of like hey hey what's up y'all good to
see you good you got to run your nose
yeah
it was you know it was it felt
it fell off it was a lot of little stuff
you guys catch it yet from that time
uh I remember
a couple months in
I was I was dropping off a tarot card
that I was I was written out here and
then uh
I was running late
but I wanted to I didn't want to get it
watched before I dropped it back off and
I was like hey man I'm running late I
gotta stop at the car wash he's like no
don't worry about it
and that's it no doubt cause it's
because I hadn't had no nothing to do so
long I'm like you want to go to the car
don't take this from you're not taking
this errand from me dog I am I'm going
to the car wash
and then
the car wash hits differently when you
ain't been doing [__] that's just a
whole production it's you know the car
started moving water I was like oh man
this [__] is
the car wash after you've been in the
crib on pandemic mobile and the car wash
hit like surprised if you're a guy in a
car wash that [__] is like if you really
like yeah it's a trip it's a man you
know it made me just appreciated like
damn this car wash it's fire dog I mean
like how do I what can I take away from
this car wash reply to my show uh as
somebody who does has done skits on
albums before and he's a fan you know
skits are a lost art form in hip-hop
especially on albums I don't hear skits
ever really but uh are you gonna do any
skits on the uh on on your body work are
you kind of staying away from that
because it might be expected no uh we
have some
necessarily skits yeah we have a couple
of just different
pieces of other interviews that I've
heard
we got you know we're using some stuff
as interlude from uh
Jam sessions just little dope moments
for that I remember from Jam sessions
that might not
you know then when that didn't
development to full songs or ideas but
you know taking right 30 seconds from
this thing this is this fun moment um
and using some stuff like that so I'll
definitely am really try and trying to
figure out how to make it cohesive and
have a lot of dope parts and and little
little moments because it has some fun
jams man where you know that's what I
like about creating music is that most
of them I could kind of pinpoint you
know exactly when what you know what
what else happened that day sometimes
with with when I made certain songs
um and the and it's a time capsule for
for that so uh you know like really
digging into the archives for a little
bit and and making it a
it's gonna be dope
project because the production is
already set so it just need some a
little more just some writing fine
tuning yeah fine tuning but the
the
is I'm I'm hyped man I'm so hyped give
me the rundown what's uh what albums
have you done skits on like for and for
who uh open my Google
static selector
Lil Dicky
cool kids
[__] lots of cool kids uh
I feel like
I'm um
I feel like that's something else I
featured on quella Chris and Jean Gray's
project uh
rapping on there love Jean Gray Jean
Gray really dope quella's super dope
um
yeah I think I feel like I'm forgetting
something on the on the uh were you on
the Little Dicky professional rappership
yeah yeah uh
there was a in 2019
88 keys
he hit me up about doing a skit like he
wanted me to kind of do the skits
throughout the album right the narrative
art
and
uh at the time I was starting to get
into my rap I just got my studio I was
kind of I said yeah Everton I didn't
really I didn't say yeah fully I was
just kind of like yeah yeah yeah and
then he was asking and I was like man
I'm really
I feel like doing this and said you know
and I've been delanding for a while
I say uh similar to music so I can get a
feel for the for the whole thing so I
can know what I'm doing throughout
and he sent the tracks
and then one of the tracks was
him
Anderson
yay
and an open verse and you sent back the
open verse with the verse and I did my
skits in there and then I like I
recorded this open verse
you know even if it never goes out I got
a track with pack and yay you sent it
back to him I said it back to him yeah
just because you never know right you
never know yeah I I thought about
leaking it but I I was like you know
what nah I'm not gonna leave it but it
was just it felt it felt good to just do
that [__] man just have it and then you
can just listen to that for yourself
like yeah this is what I would sound
like a lung some some Legends yeah I was
saying I can't believe yay's on a track
with me of saying you yo that's a nice
Flex though like you could just like for
people who don't know about everybody oh
you never want to look on you and play
for you oh yes and label [__] nowadays
without artificial intelligence anybody
could have a I just did you see the
video of Timberland
being very excited about having an AI
biggie verse on one of his Beats hey why
don't you just get acapella somehow
and it was like
I think he's like rapping about like pop
smoke and dog
it's [__] you know it's fun to toy with
stuff and no it's fun
so but you could you could feel it
though even if it sounds dope and I was
like yeah this is it it's it's it
doesn't
yeah you could feel you still could feel
the AI is not quite
yeah the Soul's there you know I hope it
never gets there by the way because then
we're gonna be [__] [__]
no it's always gonna be somebody a lot
of these movies are gonna start to come
true
well here's the thing regular artists
have haters so the AI haters is gonna
always flag [__] and all the time uh but
AI is a good
out an excuse if if you put out a verse
that you'll be like yo that wasn't even
me that wasn't me yo what are you
talking I wouldn't I wouldn't betray
y'all like that you know I got bars or
even like imagine like Hulk Hogan has
another racist ass voicemail good lead
yeah he could be like hey brother that
was AI that was AI
not this time yeah that's good you know
that's gonna happen there's gonna be all
kinds of like wild like yeah they're
just gonna be able to it isn't out to
not get canceled that's artificial
intelligence Ai and then the AI that was
you
all right so album coming soon July 21st
is my my targeting date July 21st is my
yeah are you documenting any of this I
am okay because I feel like this is you
know this is definitely this also feels
like it could be like
a pretty good like FX show
I thought about yeah about just uh like
just like the struggles of Hannibal
Burris like becoming an up-and-coming
artist yeah a couple people pitched me
on it I've got a couple you know like a
show that kind of mirrors the reality
like you know how like Louie had his
show and yeah you know Dave's show is
amazing yeah Little Dicky show is great
do you like it yeah man this season's
well done I was just watching uh the uh
Jackson Mississippi episode
super behind on this side okay I've only
seen the first two I haven't had time to
like hone in on I like to I'm waiting
for it to finish and then I'll just
watch them all yeah they're doing stuff
when you see the vision somebody
visionfully you know it's almost like it
was like his plan the whole time like
you know yeah I mean the type of
you know his music was very story and
you know the videos were super detailed
and everything and he's a he's a you
know he got a he got a lot of thoughts
and he's able to put them
the episode he had with uh Benny Blanco
where they're like did you watch that
one yes from season two were they like
best friends and they're hanging out all
day it's the most white people humor
[__] of all time it is like they're
doing so much I was like
they really had to film that yeah yeah
well so uh album hopefully you say July
right July 21st is the oh that's the
date that's the date okay that's the
date but you know how albums work but
July 21st because I yeah I gotta hold on
a venue for New York another video so
that's where it's July 21st that's an
exclusive man July 21st album is coming
we have a
album title that's kind of a placeholder
placeholder that's one of them teetering
on the edge of reality yes yes you know
it's decent I lift weights is the next
single I lift weights next single do you
lift weights no
cap
this is all cap it's cap I mean weights
weights is a metaphor for whatever you
know weights is that no man I just heard
that sample of I heard I've listened to
one of those uh we're watching the mic'd
up NFL
and uh
it was it was saying hella funny [__]
but it was Joe Hayden from the Steelers
and he's the way he said that [__] I
left whites and it just cut you know
something she just cuts through in a way
and then he's a cornerback right he's a
cornerback and so we clipped that and
just you know just put that in the bank
and then do you have to give Joe Hayden
any Pub probably yeah yeah it's fair
we should probably cut this because the
NFL is going to come for you bro you
think the NFL oh the NFL's the worst
okay they're gonna want their cut it's
probably an NFL films thing or HP it's
probably NFL films yeah yeah they don't
play you can't even say Super Bowl out
loud on the radio during Super Bowl
season you have to say the big game or
they'll sue you
it's pretty crazy
I'm ready to fight are you a Bears fan
I don't really put too much stake in
football like that basketball basketball
is where I put for some of my energy
football is just yeah so being from
Chicago sure you're spoiled growing up
you got Michael Jordan you got the rules
then there's like the Dark Age where you
get art tests and Jamal Crawford and
Eddie Curry and Tyson Chandler and then
then there's this Spike of Derrick Rose
right now the team's just kind of like
there's good players good names solid
yes Purgatory a little bit but it feels
like there's just like no end game right
so it's like do you like root for
players at that point well they the the
Lonzo
poor lingerie because they had like last
year they had that run where they were
the one seed and they looked great
Caruso and yeah yeah so Lonzo was a big
part of that stretching the floor and
distribute it so gotta get rid of
vucevic
yeah you'll see you know I don't know
and then I I love Demar Demar I feel
like if you're gonna pick between Demar
and uh Levine you got to send Levine off
man you want to it's making too much
money you'll see man you know you work
for players though if the Bulls suck
because I'm a Suns fan and we've sucked
for so long that I just started I just
root for LeBron right now we're good
again so I you know I threw for good
basketball you know just if I am
watching the game just some good because
you now and even especially during the
regular season watching water play out
but during the regular season
the game is the game after a while and
so now it was more interesting
to to watch the the podcast or the
players and get them right let me see
what Draymond Green's saying 30 minutes
after the game said those stories or
just hearing you know
there's some great players yeah yeah if
JJ Redick break down JJ's podcast is
fine or even you know the thinking
basketball those breakdowns
um so here I I'm enjoying that that part
of it just hearing you know the the
stories around it I'm enjoying the
playoffs though too and it's it's kind
of
is well I don't you can't really I don't
even I don't know who's gonna take it
nobody knows yes and that's very rare
it's very rare you'll be like it's the
Warriors or it's the Warriors ruined
basketball for a long time shout out to
them
um yeah so it's you know
it's black you know Sports man people
said his name enjoy it it's wild to
think about July 21st album July 21st
album
SOB's day SOB's June 14th okay yeah put
them up yeah but tick is gonna be seven
dollars and 21 cents we're gonna do it
yeah
I know yeah I'm gonna get it done at the
very least of EP
7 21. we shipping we shipping yeah we
shipping something I got I you know it
but they're not we're gonna get it done
we're gonna get it done over next few
weeks to focused on it's it's in a good
it's in a good space it's uh
excited the tour man and and and just
get moving darling thank you for having
me
I was like hell yeah this is great I'm
like we gotta have him man yeah yeah I'm
I'm excited for the for the music man
thank you appreciate you pulling up
brother so yes sir yeah Hannibal Buress